[Music]
[Music]
that's how we get this party started
Thursday July 14th 90 days from me
shooting a special I'm [ __ ] ready
[ __ ] uncle Joey here we ain't [ __ ]
around today you understand me the sun's
out the birds are chirpin the [ __ ]
trees are beautiful I ain't feeling too
good still Elvis is dead little feel so
good myself my nose a little clock I
just blew a [ __ ] coke Rock wrapped up
in blood and [ __ ] it's not pilot to
Bombardier [ __ ] will come with deep
into the murky waters of the underworld
next Thursday I don't know how to bring
one [ __ ] boy on Thursday
tremendous stupendous I don't know what
else to tell you had my [ __ ] smoothie
I gotta have some yogurt now because the
antibiotics if not you won't [ __ ]
I took a tremendous [ __ ] yesterday
because I've been drinking kombucha
juice and the [ __ ] yogurt and the
whole thing yeah but that's it we're
here tonight I don't have much of my
plate just a lot of writing
I still got that boom cookie from
prorating of Jesus from the Joseph and
Mary made this King Louie is king boys
of [ __ ]
but it's good to be around it's good to
be in motion you understand I've been
relaxing I'm taking my vitamins get the
blood back up my lost a lot of blood but
it don't matter [ __ ] you gotta keep
moving [ __ ] forward ain't even got no
time to [ __ ] bleed that's the problem
in America is remember you must take a
vacation everybody wants to do this no
[ __ ] you so you got a plow through this
[ __ ] every type of Joey what's with the
chitter chatter [ __ ]
drop that smoke up me hey what the [ __ ]
you slippin
look at dr. police is smoking my for my
breathing this reefer the whole [ __ ]
thing combined
I can't even describe to you the [ __ ]
feeling understand me
Rambo get sucked my dick this is a
little Joey baby boy it stirs there we
got [ __ ] no arrows no balls
this is straight-up cannon coming out of
your [ __ ] dick my friend grab your
balls and let these [ __ ] know
exactly what you're talking about you
ain't that time the self and today it's
Thursday the goals are written that
meant alleys in now you got a [ __ ]
execute [ __ ] execute attack attack
attack I want to tell you that no
[ __ ] know about your own and
that's it just recovering swag get back
out there
[ __ ] these [ __ ] up with my foot
I know you understand me does the fungi
talk is still and [ __ ] attack the lungs
are still together or I'd still Punk and
the dystonia time that's all their
[ __ ] medicine store none we do but a
I've worked at that all my life and
another day gonna [ __ ] kill me
oh yeah
oh yeah discussing they going gets my
heart [ __ ] pumpkin stick it to my
[ __ ] diet while I'm out working hands
metal ball up smart with [ __ ] song
well I'm kind of tell you people I'm
trying I haven't given up yet
don't give up who gives a [ __ ] every day
push push push
make the [ __ ] Jews and that war they
had eight hundred Jews 2000 [ __ ]
whatever they [ __ ] push they push
sometimes you think like a Julian's in
plain let's fill up another poll of this
[ __ ] what is this fool cookies you
really get the date though listen you
probably wake it up you're feeling a
little cozy cold son listen have a glass
of milk smoke a [ __ ] dump and get out
there you only got one shot at living
has made no second chances at life
[ __ ] so this is it this what you
want to do right there's what you wanted
- better room then both [ __ ] do whose
will it stop you tonight they got a [ __ ]
listen they can't stop you brother they
could stop me cuz I didn't give a [ __ ] I
wasn't going out of this [ __ ] world
will [ __ ] failing at least now I did
something a little something I'm still a
criminal and get me won't you say if I
get a chance to shoplift the line that
[ __ ] gone with that but you
know that going it L know it
l know L said it okay oh yeah - Talia
beaten up
that said they will relax nobody's
arguing everybody gets along but that's
it [ __ ] you know why because
we've created this as a family
where the church [ __ ] family okay
there is a [ __ ] up world today that
means so think about what I'm telling
you we got sucked we got stopped world
or something governments get noticed
[ __ ] whatever for people Dooku's they
went on our road [ __ ] cool of the
mind
did you know that problem think about
what we're doing right now what smoke
another [ __ ] a satellite right now
the feds are watching this everybody's
watching this the [ __ ] we're watching
this that's all that matters
keep smoking that [ __ ] go out there put
your all into everything I'm telling you
like it may not be tomorrow next week
but one day you're gonna get a sign you
know you know what I'm not gonna race
[ __ ] it
and that's it that's it
I'm stumped I gotta walk the baby to
school I got a [ __ ] right a little
bit
I gotta walk around stretch out the
muscles get some blood for them I can't
lift I can't bend over if I see a doll
ability of mental music and beside that
that's it hey we put out some churches
whatever you know us we're gonna keep
puttin about and it's it I gotta go I
got [ __ ] to do and people to see but I'm
free today you want to smoke a joint you
get me a pop do it maybe I'm around we
burn another one around lunchtime what
do you think maybe we've burned on that
ledge that that's it that's all I wanna
know you know I love you that service
this ain't about nothing else I ain't
asking
dicken that they start on the right Road
right or wrong this is it said
Willoughby's yelling oh he's blowing his
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
don't talk [ __ ] with two little [ __ ]
[ __ ] pipet ago for three tonight it's
it's [ __ ] big they understand we keep
you guys up don't believe the hype don't
listen nothing it suck dick next evening
you sit with the [ __ ] circle people
with sunglasses and everybody's trailer
say the same [ __ ] CNN's regurgitate news
and then zip mercies in their cars that
means there's gotta be drop of somewhere
and I'll check it with you [ __ ]
better you know I love you [ __ ]
we're all my heart thank you for the
support
thank you for the well-wishes this is
rough though I might have a [ __ ] gonna
come to this [ __ ] but you guys drew me
to the [ __ ] wolves and loved it
stay black having their day don't let
nobody [ __ ] with you today and you ain't
walking on locals